[Music]
there's kid focused families parent
focused families and family focused
families we're a family focused family
so that means that if you want to do
water polo Eagle Scouts tennis and skeet
shooting and then that comes to the
family and the family agrees what will
keep the family healthy like we can we
you know I've got a book launch I've got
this Steve's got patience he's taking on
others you know he's a pediatrician and
he's doing this so what works for our
family right now is you can do two
extracurriculars and I'm going to have a
two-week tour not a four-week tour but
we put the family as the system that we
serve hmm it's not the kids at the
parents cost or the parents of the kids
cost it's the family and it is it is
remarkable how do you weigh if you do it
all the the voting system so to speak
Rance if you all come to the table does
everyone have equal vote in the
decision-making process aspect we don't
even [ __ ] around that it's like when
my kids like if I say like oh [ __ ] like
my kids are like ooh you can't say that
I'm like I say anything I want you can't
say that and when you're old enough you
can do whatever you want when you get
your cursing like yeah yeah you but
right now I can totally do that but it's
so we have very we talk to our kids
about everything we're super open Steve
and I both have veto power and we rarely
use it I bet I bet I pulled out my veto
card once in the last five years veto
meeting kid says I want to do X and you
say Cathy or Steve or Steve yeah I'm
like I have to veto that I cannot do
that and then we really respect the veto
because we don't over use it
so our our thing with our kids this is
my theory on parenting my my theory on
parenting is the best we can do is a
loving course
from compliance to commitment that your
kids need to do what you're asking them
to do out of compliance so don't run
into the street don't do this that's
that's you know you're not allowed to
watch that kind of TV you're not allowed
to play that kind of video game you need
to comply otherwise there's some natural
consequences at some point I've got a 14
year old now he's at other people's
house doing video right and so if all I
teach him is compliance and don't give
him the why about why you can't do that
if I don't say yes every time I can and
explain the knows then when he's there
and I can tell you that like we got a
call from a parent maybe a month ago and
said the boys were having a sleepover
they wanted to watch on though some
r-rated violent thing and Charlie said
can we watch something else you know my
parents are not cool with us and he
could he didn't have to do that
yeah but he's moved to a commitment to
our family values because we say yes
every time we can we don't do any that
stuff that my parents did because I said
no we explained so in the voting process
we'll sit down and say here's the fall
semester Charlie's like I've got guitar
I've got you know this I've got this and
I've got this I'd really love to do this
and this he's got here's what my fault
looks like you know we still keep time
in semesters here's what my time looks
like we're going to be able to do two
curriculars you can choose mm-hmm why
not
a lot of my friends are doing that's
five totally understand different
families have different ways of
operating and it's like my daughter when
she went to high school she's a junior
now in college but we sat down with her
and said the number of AP courses that
you'll take will be limited by your time
you won't go to bed past ten you will
not miss a single dance you will do
something every weekend with friends we
will not participate in the race to
nowhere like you don't need to graduate
with 40 and she's a super academic kid
and she's like what you know and like
she's like but I need to take this and
then and take this I'm like it's not
going to work that way and then when she
got to college we were like we're not
paying for it if you already know what
you want to be you're 18 so what does
that say more I'd like to hear more on
this so does that mean that you
wanted her to well actually not even
gonna speculate so could you elaborate
on that take every class that's
interesting to you mm-hmm
learn who you are because if I had a
dollar for every interview I did with a
late twenty thirty year old that got on
the engineer lawyer a doctor path
because that was the moving escalator
for smart people who was depressed hated
what they did never even knew that you
could be a shoe designer or casting
director or a microphone builder if I
had a dollar for every one of those like
set for life set for life yeah and I
said you need to explore but you know
she's like this so cringy mom is so so
cringy like everyone that freshman
orientation knows exactly what they're
gonna be where they're gonna go to grad
school I'm like that's great that's not
the way we work yeah so you know I'll
Colin like what are you taking she's
like taking a class on black power
movements Germany in the 20th century
statistics in multivariate analysis and
like great I mean granted that spells
graduate school but yeah she's like as
it turns out I don't think I want to do
this I don't want to do that and I'm
like super valuable and she's like no
are you sure it's as valuable as knowing
what you do want to do and like oh yeah
yeah knowing what you don't want to do
you get to save all the part in your 30s
and 40s where you hate work you drinking
heavily you know like you get to save a
lot of that like figure it out nothing's
wasted yeah yeah I graduate from college
when I was 29 hmm that's like go see the
world
get a job wait tables everyone I know is
better at who's waited tables a human
being yeah yeah I think everybody
everyone should have to work at least
one porifera Blee to service jobs yes
yeah yeah you really learn a lot yes yes
I mean like that and like that's what to
always tell Ellen you get one job where
you're serving the public and you have
to ever do that ever date a guy who's a
dick to a waiter
yeah yeah
you